a rally is going ahead in Paris to honor
the death of a black man who died in
police custody back in 2016. that is
despite it being banned by French
officials police intervene with one of
the protest leaders and scuffles broke
out earlier court hearing failed to
overall a ban on the march in Northwest
Paris another protest is also being held
in Marseille over the police killing of
a teenager named nael two weeks ago his
death sparked protests and riots all
across France let's go to Abdul Hamid
now in Marseille Hoda so we had days and
days of protests as a result of the
death of that teenager then things died
down does it feel like
protests could be really kicking off
again
well actually here in Marseille I think
the turnout has been quite small I mean
the March just went uh by uh right now
here there's maybe two to 300 people now
the organizers actually wanted to do
this in the city center where those
riots unfolded just last weekend but
that was denied from police so they
started actually from belmay which is
one of the poorest neighborhoods in uh
France but if you look at the Mark
makeup
of the protesters you had very little
representations of Youth from those
difficult neighborhoods uh very few uh
youth that had that come from sort of
African or North African background who
were accused being spear handing those
riots last week but the message is the
same the message is against police
brutality and now everybody is talking
about nahel that young man who was
killed in downtown near near Paris and
that sparked all that wave of anger
across the country where here in Max say
people are waiting to hear about another
young man who received a rubber bullet
last weekend doing the riots the footage
of him who shows him really sitting on
his moped and filming the riots with his
mobile phone uh well he received his
rubber bullets and eventually a shorter
leader collapses an investigation on the
way but that is something that is
actually infuriating people here they're
waiting to see the results of that and
the message coming out of these protests
is that pattern happens over and over
again has been going on for decades is
getting worse and that police needs to
be reined in and on the other hand you
had during this little march here you
had mothers of your young man who had
been killed in their neighborhood
because of the violence in their
neighborhoods and so people are also
saying when are you going to come and
protect us when are you going to come
and protect our children so certainly a
symbolic march to represent to denounce
police lack of action in certain ways
and too much action in other times but
also a message but not one where there
was a turnout and I think it's simply
because following the riots last weekend
there was a lot of finger pointing
towards those communities uh many
opinions in those communities were
actually quite mixed many people said
that the riots I didn't actually bring
any purpose and didn't honor the memory
of this Nile so I think now the attitude
of people coming from those areas is
less let's just wait and see and be on
the margin so we don't get accused again
thank you for that
person must say let's turn now to Paris
we were just looking at some live
pictures from there where we're
expecting a rally to go ahead in Paris
to honor the death of a black man who
died in police custody back in 2016 we
can speak to Paul Reese Paul what are we
expecting Where You Are
hello
[Music]
well as you say this demonstration has
actually been banned by the French
authorities it's gone ahead anyway uh
you can maybe just see a young woman
climbing down from the bus stop here uh
this is Asa triore the sister of Adam
triore who died after being arrested by
police in 2016. now this March takes
place every year on the 19th of July to
commemorate
and has become a symbol of protest
against alleged police brutality police
racism in France now it was meant to
take place in baldwaz north of Paris but
it was banned by the authorities
who is now climbed down decided to hold
it in plastered public in the center of
Paris instead that was banned this
morning but she arrived anyway now
they've been rightfully circling the
demonstrators in Republic
all day she gave a press conference and
afterwards she was she was manhound or
by the police as her supporters tried to
get her along to this demonstration but
they've managed to make the journey up
from plaster of La Republic uh up to
here where assatori's been addressing
the crowd saying that these killings are
based on police Prejudice police
brutality
um and and racism the police didn't want
it to go ahead because they believe it
will inflame tensions and lead to some
of the writing we saw in the wake of the
killing of Nutella uh nearly two weeks
ago on the other hand the protesters
have said well if you don't let us
protest then tensions are just going to
get worse it seems that we've had the
worst of Both Worlds because people here
are pretty angry that their voices have
tried to be quieted
thank you for that Paul Reese there for
us in Paris